c'est la vérité oui beaucoup trop
d'argent une fourchette enfin plusieurs
dizaines de milliers
la vérité ou non plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de doses par mois mais non
mécanique du président la vérité dix
mille euros oui mais tentant d'entrer de
quoi tu as autant d'entrées pour
dépenser autrement oui le dos 15 bien
oui plus de 20000
oui quoi le départ de sa mine de
m'arrêter
j'arrive le chroniqueur s'est pas pris
en révélant cette somme
faribault chaque mois pharaonique je
rappelle que ça vient du ca rien entendu
et on embrasse ramsès deux
issus de il a
été honnête il n'a pas menti cela dit
les choses alors oui c'est vrai guillon
alors non mais vous êtes choqués par ces
lignes ont déjà avant qu'il répond parce
que moi je trouve on est honnête on dit
les choses vont s'en prendre les uns
c'est horrible les 5 millions alors
sachez qu'un film barney's n'aura pas là
mathieu alors jouer le match mcee qui
charrie en argent et en perte
d'autonomie évidemment il extrêmement
honnête moi j'en avais fait la même
erreur des trains de dette sur ce que je
gagne et on me l'a activement reproché à
céret mais on est dans un pays où ou
alors que ces clichés on se voile la
face on ne peut pas dire combien on
gagne c'est toujours mal perçue est mal
vécue ils bossent énormément et je vais
très honnête images mais vraiment
plusieurs pas plus de douze heures par
jour vahid 11.250 maintenant emon henri
bosco et et tant mieux pour lui s'il
peut dépenser grand bien lui fasse
pourquoi faire un procès tout le temps
aux gens qui gagnent de l'argent qu'il
dépense c'est vrai je suis désolé alors
c'est que peut-être vraiment ça se crée
mon avis ça va sauter l'honore mais
voilà je veux dire plus qu'il a il était
drogué l'autre
et en plus j'ai un prénom peu ces
connards l'avancé quand même ça et en
plus c'est vrai que le clip est dans ce
pays dans ce métier en particulier dans
le showbiz tout le monde passe son temps
à mentir tous les animateurs tous les
producteurs montrent 116 est donc normal
pour vous tirer c'est parce que parce
que vous cyril vous n'avez pas désiré
pas d'argent on le sait
dépenser plus de 5000 euros par mois
[Rires]
on
m'a pas demandé moi hier donc je suis
pas dans le débat ici et
c'est vrai qu'il ne faut jamais répondre
à cette question parce qu'on se fait des
désaccords monture intel film mais en
fait si guillaume gagne son argent parce
qu'il travaille beaucoup et qui les
dépensent proportionnellement à lui à ce
qu'il gagne je vois pas qu'est ce qu'on
a à dire là dessus et puis on a un plan
et puis il fait tourner l'économie non
mais c'est ça que
sert elle a bola personnes apparemment
il a volé à personne tu as un mec qui
peut se plaindre c'est moi non mais
voilà il s'est tourné l'économie donc
c'est you may ont envie que tout le
monde gagne très très bien l'idée c'est
pas que les riches gagnent moi c'était
l'époque gagne plus
et il n'a pas volé son argent et travail
et les profiteurs donc après il indiqué
comment le nom j'ai évidemment je sache
hodges
18h et comment des pires pas donc toi
mais les gens qui travaillent comme des
bollards gagneront jamais ce concombre
est du matin et fini très tard we found
love la nuit il est produit en meurt
c'est pas à quoi ça quoi ah non mais ça
c'est pas faim c'est pas un argument me
dire c'est pas un argument de grave ils
nous envoient de l'argent bah si c'est
un argument
qui disait quand on donne son salaire à
l'antenne soit c'est indécent mais son
nom et il avait raison parce qu'elle
part et on donne beaucoup d'argent c'est
indécent voilà on fait ça on a tous un
peu hier soir en allant team a menti ça
c'est dur à entendre parce qu'il ya des
gens qui travaillent douze heures par
jour très surfait qui gagne sa raison il
ya des vérités qu'il a gagné moi ça me
choque pas ce qu a dit guillaume et ça
c'est choquant je vais faire après
beaucoup de gens je pense que c'est
choquant bête de mode charles débat du
jour
ça va ça vous arrêtez envie de fraises
ou en fait
mais ça fait plaisir
on a on l'a dénoncé on va entendu le mec
qui est relaté martial nous ayons des
brochets en régie la nuit pour faire des
économies on économise s'emballe par
mois quand on a des branches
merci alors vers des zones et la réponse
est non mais ce qui choque c'est la
manière dont il a dit ça pour pour avec
une certaine nonchalance une certaine
facilité droit pour tous les gens qui
ont du mal à remplir leurs caddies au
supermarché voilà je lui reproche pas de
gagner leur vie dans la ville n'a pas
craché sur le g absolument pas dit ça ce
qui choque c'est le montant qui
l'amènerait ce que c'est simple pardon
parce que cette choc bah oui non mais
qu'est-ce que ça dure que montant qu'il
a donnée on peut pas dire ça aujourd'hui
alors que l'enjeu
de quoi ça j'ai personnellement je lui
reproche avec une certaine voilà comme
si c'était comme si ça coulait de source
de dire je dépense 20
de dire oui c'est ça ma millions par
mois tu les prendras celle dont on n'a
jamais dit qu'on serait pas c'est pas ça
tu es bon ce n'est pas de la manière
dont il a dit je dépense ça comme si
c'était tout à fait normal
donc ça peut changer du
tout dans la culture américaine parler
d'argent c'est pas du tout aux états
unis
parler je comprends que ça puisse
choquer parce que c'est des montants
énormes mais en même temps je trouve
qu'il n'a pas il était pas arrogant il
l'a dit pour dire la vérité mais il
était même un petit peu un petit peu
gêné et donc
mais je comprends que ça puisse choquer
des gens qui gagnent le smic on est
vraiment vraiment après ma tout parce
que c'est ce métier qui veut ça moi j'ai
toujours dit ici il ya beaucoup il ya
beaucoup d'argent là quand il a dit ça
les gens sont selon prix pourrait on dit
moi il me faut un an pour gagner ça
hélas qui dit en un mois il faut un an
donc évidemment qu'il y pensant à moi
une fois ce qu'ils dépensent en un mois
les gens vont regarder ils ont pensé à
leur déclaration d'impôts il anime donc
lui ce qu'il fait en un mois il faut un
an donc ça peut choquer maintenant il il
a volé à personne et il a été honnête et
il l'a dit et autour de la table il y en
a bien à bourg où on et prenez beaucoup
il y en a beaucoup qui sont aussi à
20000 euros peut-être par mois ou 15000
euros par mois pas très loin donc moi ça
me choque pas trop il a été honnête
c'est bien qu'il est honnête mais les
gens sont pas prenne enfin de ça des
gens sont pas prêts c'est un mec bourré
de personnes en est par contre pas
donner de noms je vois personne de
personnes en blues boss c'est pour le
monsieur kita
quand on travaille beaucoup c'est à dire
des gens ils ont deux métiers ce que je
dis même en cuir sur
le maire entrant minimisation y
travaille le week-end ils font des
travaux il ya plein de gens mais en deux
trois métiers ils font trois quatre
mille balles pas plus oui mais c'est
toujours agaçant ce le début
de l'année elle s'est opposée concernant
les riches au pour cause il dit qu'il
est riche alors c'est méchant pour les
poulains mais pas du tout c'est parce
qu'on est en train de dire et je peux
poser une question à béatrice à béatrice
oui alors oui mais question alors de
coeur et je ne m'en a jamais cessé ses
revenus mais pour un film comme john
cusack ou des gros films américains à la
journée c'est combien acteurs ça dépend
du cv ça dépend du rôle ça dépend c'est
un film si c'est une série citons
récurrent pour
quatre fils un gros film le truc c'est
que si tu étais en salaire mais tu
gagnes aussi beaucoup d'argent royalties
c'est à dire que le film repasse et
pendant des années ouais tu touches
voilà et on envoie des chèques même
onze de tennis et scapa fuyumi r ouais
guillaume hier il a dit 20000 là on n'a
pas de mon temps on sait pas faire
christophe d'yvoire pas les autres c'est
pas ça
mais hier il a dit demander il a dit -
honnêtement je vole pas l'argent on me
le donne je le prends je propose des
trucs en télé
je le prends là on ne m'en pose une
question simple
mont rigi mon guillaume qu'est-ce qui se
passe non mais alors déjà je ne serais
jamais permis de dire ça spontanément si
on voyage et la question parce que je
trouve ça vulgaire et je déteste affiché
jeu mais rien sur les réseaux sociaux
etc et je comprends que ça puisse
choquer voilà très honnêtement ensuite
vous m'avez posé une question j'ai
répondu j'ai dit la vérité voilà je suis
producteur j'ai plusieurs sociétés
seraient pas qu on television donc lui
qui gagne très bien ma vie j'ai dit que
je dépensais effectuant plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros je
comprends que ça puisse choquer mais moi
j'en ai marre de tous ces faux culs qui
travaille à la télé dans les médias qui
ont des boîtes qui disent aux gens je
gagne 4000 euros par mois alors qu'ils
en gagnent 100 mille deux cent mille
trois cent mille quatre cent mille
[Applaudissements]
plus que tu le crois ah bon bah oui bah
merde alors les producteurs
j'aime bien je connais pas beaucoup de
gens à part des nagui et tout ça qui
gagnent 2 300 400 mille euros par mois
quand même chocolat
il est dit lui-même kennedy lui dans des
interviews qui gagnent entre 1 million
et demi et 3 millions d'euros par un
parent
qui
dit ça quoi séduire à bill
wiggin ce qui m'énerve c'est que j'ai lu
plein écran mais j'ai lu plein de
messages et d' insulte bon voila mais il
ya plein de gens qu'ils oublient de son
sahara entier c'est un héritier ça voilà
moi maintenant un métier normal j'ai
commencé à travailler à 17 ans même
avant voilà je me lève le matin pour
travailler c'est toujours n'ai pas honte
et encore une fois jamais je la
ficherait et je trouve ça extrêmement
vulgaire de dire combien gagnent
maintenant si on me pose la question je
suis honnête et je réponds je dis la
vérité c'est tout d'accord merci à ces
beaux
[Applaudissements]